rentner oraze peli waren ist mir
zugeschaltet gemeinsam mit seiner frau
aus duisburg hallo ihnen ganz herzlich
willkommen auch ihnen frau sengül ganz
herzlich willkommen
sie sind momentan in häuslicher
quarantäne sie sind aus der türkei
gekommen am 26 juni sind eingereist über
passau
aufgrund der dort stand finden den tests
um dann halten zurück nach duisburg köln
zu kommen zu können zum schulstart mit
ihrer tochter ja und jetzt sind sie in
duisburg und mussten sich noch einmal
testen lassen oder wie es ihre der
derzeitige situation ja wir waren so in
der türkei wir haben am 19
august zurück gefallen nach deutschland
wir wollten so cordula test machen
lassen
in passau deswegen wir sind nach passau
erfahren so ist es zentral
wir haben schon gemacht die bahn leute
normalerweise sehr nett sehr freundlich
test gemacht werden
danach nach duisburg gefahren wir bis
dienstag nachmittag gewartet dass
ergebnisse erwarten aber nicht gekommen
und musste nochmal also mittwochs zur
schule geht deswegen wir haben gehört
auch wir haben gefragt zum statt
wir machen hier auch test gottes aber
die silvia bis dienstagnachmittag immer
im kanton bleiben weil die eltern nichts
wenn werden muss ist diese seien
wir möchten nicht dass andere leute
irgendeine wahl stellen
dann wie die sitze nach duisburg
gegangen wir haben test gemacht
gestern nachmittag testergebnisse
gekommen aber von passau bis heute immer
noch nicht gekommen so seit fünf tagen
erfahren
das ergebnis sind gewinnen also seit
fünf tagen warten sie auf ihre
testergebnisse aus passau und das obwohl
sie ja sozusagen den umweg in kauf
genommen haben und sich ja vorbildlich
verhalten haben zu hause geblieben sind
in quarantäne um niemanden anzustecken
wie war ihre erfahrung denn dort bei den
tests in passau wie liefen die ab haben
sie gesehen wie die dort sind die
mitarbeiter mit diesen bleistiften
tatsächlich die formulare ausgefüllt
haben wie lief das ab welche eindrücke
haben sie da also die waren alle
maskiert also ganz normal wie das sein
sollte
und da haben wir auch so eine extra
kugelschreiber bekommen und so einen
fragebogen nachdem wir das alles
ausgefüllt haben dürften wir die
bleistifte auch behalten also wir
mussten das nicht zurück abgebe
und es wurde aber auch tatsächlich
händisch alles bearbeitet alles per hand
ausgefüllt computer waren da und
zumindest wo sie waren nicht vorhanden
richtig also da war kein computer wir
haben da nichts gesehen dass man alles
nicht also die hatten so hingestellt mit
so fragebogen und stifte
also mit computer gab es da gar nichts
wie geht es jetzt für sie weiter sie
haben jetzt in duisburg noch einen test
gemacht
der ist jetzt schon ist das schon das
ergebnis da ja ja die haben wir auch
gestern bekommen es ist alles negativ
auch alle drei da sieht man hat klar
etwas beruhigte aber die andere sache
das war schon ärgerlich also wie man
wirklich genervt also auch psychisch
sind wir auch fertig gewesen weil wir
nicht wissen was wir jetzt haben ob das
jetzt positiv ist ob das jetzt negativ
ist das war wirklich sehr sehr schlimm
also meine tochter die beuthener klar
unbedingt zur schule dürfte aber nicht
ist ja wohl klar das war sehr
anstrengend sag ich mal so die zeit wenn
man da so in der schwebe ist und wartet
auf das ergebnis und auch ja stark in
sich hört habe ich da was ist das
vielleicht problematisch oder macht man
sich gedanken mein ergebnis kommt
vielleicht so spät bald positiv ist und
sie wollen einfach noch mal auf nummer
sicher gehen welche beck gedanken hat
man während dieser zeit in der schwebe
in dieser wartezeit im kopf also unser
kopf war wirklich sehr sehr voll war mit
einem eigentliche unkonzentrierter gehen
nur mit dem gedanken da war
wir waren wirklich sehr oft am handy
gewesen ist dass jetzt da ist das jetzt
also dieses thema war die letzten
wirklich drei vier tagen nur noch diese
krone tesco ist es also wir wollten
endlich mal wissen das war so was von
egal ob das positiv heraus kommt
hauptsache wir haben eine ergebnis also
das zuwarten ist wirklich sehr sehr
schlimm gewesen
unsere tochter so sehr schrecklichen
also die war auch an beinen gewesen die
war auch total nervig kaputt was habe
ich jetzt warum kriegen wir keine
ergebnisse und das war wirklich sehr
anstrengend die letzten tagen dass frau
so lange dauert so lange dauert warum
unsere site ist
genau das ist ja nicht nur die tochter
den ich in die schule kann ihr ganzes
leben stand ja auch still
jetzt sprechen wir ja hier mit ihnen
weil das jetzt groß an die
öffentlichkeit kamen diese recherche
diese vielen fällen 9 100 an der zahl
wenn wir jetzt gleich nach münchen
schalten in wenigen minuten soll ja da
der ministerpräsident und die
gesundheitsministerin vor die kameras
treten was fordern sie denn was wollen
sie denn hören von den verantwortlichen
aus bayern
also das mit dem test das musste schon
schneller sein damit will damit die
leute auch beruhigt sind ist egal ob das
positiv oder negativ heraus kommt die
sollen wirklich die ergebnisse haben bei
das ist wirklich sehr sehr anstrengend
auch psychisch ist man da auch kaputt
also das war vielleicht auch eine stelle
hat wo man auf anrufen kann da gab es
zum beispiel nummern auf dem malteser
hat das alles also gemacht das stand
auch diese nummern wo wir auch anrufen
könnten aber
es ist es keiner erreichbar dass man
wenigstens jemanden erreichen kann
eine auskunft bekommen kann also solche
nummern sind nämlich auch sehr wichtig
also wir haben da keine hilfe bekommen
gar nichts auch im internet haben wir
auch geschrieben nichts also wir haben
wir keine antwort bekommen ich habe
dreimal gestiegen
und wir sind nicht so 16 wir haben eine
facebook-seite für die unterwegs
barcelona punkte kommt dies für die
urlauber circa 170.000 erfolge ich habe
ich diese zeit auch ich habe viel zu
viel gesehen und gelesen viele hat so
kein ergebnisse bekommen
die schreiben immer wir hatten auch so
lange zeit